All right. Welcome to another Zoom call. We got some questions to go over and then we'll open it up for questions. Again, remember to submit your questions on the membership site. If you're having trouble getting on the membership site or you don't even know there is a membership site.
Email me at info at cuttersclinic.com and I can get you another invite to the membership site. All right. Let's get started. Now the reminder to look to answer, see if your questions have already been answered. Go to the website, a regular website and you can do a search.
And you can type in that search panel. What you're looking for. Maybe I did a video on something. Maybe I did a blog post on what you're looking for. I don't know.
Also, we're getting less questions. So I think the membership site is also healthy. So we only have a few questions to go over. Let's get started.
With regard to cast or oil packs understand this is our cast or oil pack of description here. I just pulled it off the internet.
How much value is there to just play cast or oil to the skin over the liver without using topical packs.
Well, heat will help drive the cast or oil help you absorb the cast or oil a better than if you just put cast or oil over your skin. So heat is is something that can open up your pores and help drive the cast or that's the idea of the cast or all pack.
One of the things that people have struggled with the cast or all packs is that it's a messy and it takes time out of your day and good to say, I don't have time to do another thing like that.
Well, I recommend just using hot water bottle or one of those infrared heating pads. Those are my favorite.
If that just over your liver without the cast or oil, if that helps just to throw have a hot pack near you that infrared heating pad.
Have it already plugged in to where you line out or sit down or where you're going to sit and watch TV or read a book and you can put that over your liver that can help. So just heat can help cast or oil and heat is maybe a step better.
Just another thing to help with your detox.
I had a tumor in my colon and has now been removed. There were signs of cancer in the lymph nodes.
The C-A-125 is the blood test that would be recommended for me is the C-A-125 blood test recommended for me is that what I had done. That is what I had done at the hospital before and after the surgery.
So I did a screenshot of a blog post that I wrote about tumor markers. So you can find it by going to the blog or website and looking here to search tumor markers.
So I just did a screenshot of my tumor marker blog post in number five is the C-A-125 cancer antigen 125.
It's useful for monetary or variant cancer liver cancer colon cancers, etc.
But also the C-E-A is another tumor marker for colon cancer. That's another helpful one for colon cancer to look for as well. So think about getting that one.
So if your C-A-125 was normal prior to the surgery and normal within normal ranges after the surgery, it might not be the most valuable test to run as a monetary tool because it's within normal ranges.
So with colon cancer, it's really the C-A-125 or the C-E-A. Those are really early two options for tumor markers. So I would request those.
Now that I've had the Syrex 10 results, this is person who did a Syrex 10. So Syrex 10 is a food sensitivity test.
So that's what that is. So it's a food sensitivity test to measure antibodies in your blood for different foods, test 300 different foods.
In this person, she had no food sensitivities except to cook scallops. Well, that's easy enough to eliminate those under your diet. Do I still need to take his to clear or histamine scavenger and do a low histamine diet?
So if you have food sensitivities, you are going to have a lot of inflammation and you're got from that food sensitivity.
But you can have inflammation, you're got four other reasons. So let me finish this question so I'll help you understand this.
What is the likely cause of the inflammation in my body that causes the graduate low months? I just read that the C-A-125 isn't a marker for a very cancer as much as the marker for inflammation is that true.
Then what should I be doing to lower the inflammation besides the protocol you've given me? So this is a person like so many people with cancer that have inflammation.
So when you have inflammation, you do want to do your best to find the sources of inflammation and to reduce those sources of inflammation.
It's not always possible to do that for every avenue of inflammation you have going on, but you want to reduce the sources of inflammation.
Because this person had a lot of inflammation in their body, I suggested that we run a food sensitivity panel and the best one on the market now is the Syrex 10.
Syrex is the name of the lab. There are a bunch of different tests. The array 10 is their food sensitivity panel. Why would I recommend that? Well, because if you had a lot of inflammation in your body, and if it was one of the causes of it was the foods that you're eating, even though it might not be a driver of your cancer.
And really have very little to do directly with your cancer or cancer growth. It could be it could have a very direct correlation to the amount of inflammation you have. So foods can cause inflammation.
And how that happens is that if you have a leaky gut, we did a separation of your cells in the that lied your intestinal cavity, the epithelial cells, then larger proteins, larger peptides get across the gut membrane and larger than it's supposed to happen.
And then you end up creating antibodies against that peptide. So now when you eat that food in your body breaks that protein down into smaller particles called peptides.
Every time you eat it, you fire an immune reaction, you create this inflammation in the gut, which further damages the gut lining, which further causes leaky gut, which is this cascading negative cycle.
And to break that cycle, you want to get rid of eliminate those foods that you already have circulated antibodies against their peptides, so that you you cut off that inflammatory cycle.
And that being said, we were just taking a shot of the dark. We didn't know this person had any gut symptoms, but they had inflammation. So if you do have inflammation, let's start looking for sources. So we did the Syrex tendency wasn't foods.
So that's still doesn't mean you don't still do things to calm down the inflammation. So no, you would still take the histic layer, you'd still take the histamine scavenger, you'd still be on a low histamine diet, because foods that contain histamines themselves, though they might not be causing inflammation in the gut.
And two, you still might not have any other foods. They wouldn't show up on a Syrex 10, you'll still absorb that histamine. That's what's causing histamine, that's what's causing inflammation of the tissue. So no, this doesn't change your protocol whatsoever.
Are there other ways to find other inflammatory causes elsewhere in the body? Yes, there's other tests we could do.
There's a ton of different functional medicine that is a test, it really depends on how deep you want to dig. It may not change the problem is, is that, oh, we could spend thousands of thousands of dollars on functional medicine test, and it really doesn't change the way we do it any of the treatment.
If a person has deep pockets, we might want to run a mold protocol profile, we have a microtoxin profile, we might want to run a Syrex 7 to antibodies to other tissue antibodies to neural tissue and we could keep digging in this.
And I am not against that. It's just it does get costly doesn't change our protocol. Well, maybe if microtoxins came back, maybe we'd look at possible.
You know, sources of that in your house and do some more investigation. Maybe we would do, you know, change your right program where we'd be running microtoxins on your right program. So yes, digging deeper can be very valuable.
But partly it has. And so where do you stop, I guess, is the question. And I guess the answer is, well, are you improving, you know, are you getting better or are you getting worse?
And if the person is not improving, not getting better, and or they're getting worse, then I would say if if finances allows that we do keep digging and we do some of these other functional medicine tests, so we have availability to do all of them as just a matter of picking and choosing what's the best course of action.
So in one sense, it was great that your Syrex came back normal. The food sensitivity. All right, 10 came back clean. That's fantastic. But in other sense, it's shoot. That's not what our cause is. We might have to dig a little deeper.
Hopefully that helps explain that.
Do you know any good mold restoration companies in Minnesota, one that will travel to said for Minnesota, I heard that 90% of them are no good.
But we did head ERMI test and found that we have high levels of mold and need to get it out of our home. Yeah, mold is a big culprit for a lot of problems and certainly can be it just the causing it back to inflammation might not be the cause of the cancer.
But it's certainly a cause of constant inflammation, which is which makes it difficult for your immune system to be able to deal with cancer or any serious disease.
So getting some mold testing your house could be valuable, but then how do you figure out where the mold is?
The picture that I pulled off the internet here through the easy to see where the black mold is, but many times it's behind the wall that you, you know, you have a slow drip of copper fitting behind your bathroom wall and you don't have her head have any water leaking out to know where it's at.
So the two by fours and all the inside of the sheet rock is all black mold behind your your bedroom that you're sleeping and you just don't know what he's supposed to do just start tearing sheet rock out of your house.
Very difficult.
So taking care of mold in your home, finding a good contractor can be difficult as well.
Firstly, I don't know of anybody in Minnesota or anywhere that is going to be able to do that you're going to have to find a contractor that you trust.
And I just don't have a good source for you. I'm sorry about that.
We used to have a person on a company that would do would come in and do some testing.
And you certainly can get the plates to test for mold at your house that's really inexpensive, but to have a contractor do the work and actually find the source and do the cleaning of the mold and replace things that it gets that it gets more difficult.
The thing you can try to lead is what we recommended in multiple other zoom calls is using one of those little ear purifiers.
Let me pull it up and I'll show you a picture of it.
I have one in my office here.
Where I am.
And we have one at our house. We actually have one of these in multiple staff people's office because it actually acts as a nice white noise.
It looks like this. This is the little unit right here.
It was very inexpensive. It's not very big.
I didn't get it by daughter one. I really like this little unit. I just pulled it off Amazon. That's where I got it. 150 bucks on Amazon.
It's got two UV lights. That's really the ozone that's going to be a killer of mold. So remember in our discussion of ozone what ozone is is 0302 is oxygen that you would breathe.
It can be as an extra oxygen on an old to molecule. It's very unstable. So ozone being unstable is used to our advantage typically it's given to organisms living organisms and that extra oxygen can oxygen that and kill that organisms.
It's very good for killing mold. So having one of these in your bedroom, at least, but you want to put it high on a shelf because all three is heavier than old to so as the fan blows it out.
Then you will, you know, it goes out into the into the space.
This little unit is not going to be enough to to cause too much ozone you'll have a smell of ozone is to gentle smell of ozone too much ozone breed it can be damaging to your lungs. This would never have that enough to damage your lungs.
And this but it also will not be enough to treat your whole home either. So you probably want one of these at every larger space of your house.
But they're cheap enough to get a few of them for sure. We've had people there's also some larger ones. We actually have two larger ones before this one.
Came out on the market that were a little bit expensive but put out a lot more ozone that are meant for a whole house or whole floor unit. We have two of those in our office as well.
And they're nice. They're great units too.
But you could actually use those two to put down the basement we've had patients use them down the basement where they know that at least they think the source of the mold is.
And if you get those mold plates, then you can test where the greatest amounts and mark with the marker on the model plate where where you place the plate where the greatest amount of mold spores are.
So that give you an idea where you want to concentrate treatment.
This, of course, is not the solution if you got mold growing on your studs inside the wall. It's not a solution for really bad mold problems, but it's worth trying this and then writing that test again, do another play test and see, you know, if it improves the situation.
So something to look at.
Okay, that's all the questions that came in for you guys. So anything else you might have a question about.
Okay, I wear an EMF blocking pendant. Should I remove this, but I use the right note, you should keep you see that it's not going to affect the right frequencies at all.
Um, we recently did mold remediation on our home. One place to start is your AC system, including ductwork to make sure it is clean. Good, good. Thank you. Great comment.
I've received new program flash drive for my right protocols and footpath. Can you tell me more about the updates? Sure, we talked about that the last couple of Zoom calls. Please, if you did receive an updated program from a run that updated program.
I've just made some improvements. I don't have everybody's done. So not everybody has received one of those yet and they are only for people who have the F122.
So it's going to cause your ball to be a little less right.
And it will cause your machine to run a little less hot. So your machine will run a little cooler. The ball will be a little cooler.
Much less chance of blowing fuses or the little thing on the back of the machine, but it is actually a more powerful program. So, um, they're excited about that. So please run your new program.
Okay, I have some questions. I did not get into you the time.
Please address whatever is prudent here. Are there any therapies that should not be done at the same time? That's a really great question.
How do you do the hypothermia and the pdf at the same time? Theoretically, yes, it's just a matter of situating the units. So there should not be any issue with that pdf at right. Yes, of course, you can do that pdf in the footbat.
I don't know. I don't know. I would say theoretically, I'm sure there's no problem, but you're using an electrical device or you're at your feet and water. I don't know. Maybe it was me. I'd say no on that.
I know the company would say it's fine, but I would probably say no on that.
I recently asked a question about parasite identification and have continued to pass what appears to be mucoate plaques.
Perhaps better would be to ask what does it matter whether it is ID clearly as parasite or mucus or is it just good either way. That's coming out. It is good either way.
There are there is a parasite called a rope worm. You might have you might want to search for that on Google rope R O P E. It was discovered by a university, a Minnesota professor, but he's also been poo pooed in some parasitologist say there's no such thing as rope worm because it looks like a mute. It looks like this long street mucus.
We've had people pass those. I think it truly does exist. We've had people pass those.
You know, for a period of time and it stops. So I don't buy. So look up back to it doesn't particularly make a difference what the identification of that parasite is, but it's kind of fun to know. I like to know.
So what's you, I think, to identify it would be good. All good. You did look it up and it matches the idea. I think they do exist because I just do. I just see that I have people bring them in, you know, jar. So heavy.
Have you had anybody use the black stab and anyone in the medical field assist the use of black stab for a client. You could refer me to.
We currently, we've had dozen people do the black stab for melanoma or squamous cell, the skin.
At least that my wife did the black stab melanoma two spots of melanoma.
And I'm convinced she wouldn't be here if she had knocked out a thousand 90 years ago.
And we have eight to 10 women currently using a black stab on their breast cancer. So you can't really use black stab until the cancer has come to the surface.
So you can't use, let's say you have a deep breast tumor, you can't put black stab on there. I think it's going to draw the tumor out. It really won't draw more than, you know, you know, a tenths of a millimeter deep, you know, just a few layers of skin over the top.
But if you have an open wood, you can certainly use black stab on the tumor and it has pros and cons. So we do assist with that. And I know that you could probably get a local that your path or something to help you with that too.
I actually have a putting together a black stab manual and little booklet to help people with that too. Also concerning mold by a humanist stand to control the level of humidity in your house that could be very good.
Obviously, a mold really comes from.
So it has to be water source of water in a source of organic material. So the back, the sheet rock that is made of paper. So that's an organic material that mold likes to grow on. Of course, wood, it likes to grow on. So, that's the two things that you're looking for.
And how do you feel about whole body cryotherapy as an anti-cancer treatment or cancer therapy? Well, I know cryotherapy can be beneficial to use for different cancers.
Whole body cryotherapy is just I wouldn't say it's a cancer therapy. But it's an anti-inflammatory therapy. So going into cryotherapy takes can be very beneficial to calm down inflammation.
Every person to truth is every person is a little bit different. So let's say you have some inflammation at your knee and you put some ice on it and really, really helps. So that that's what really helps decrease the inflammation.
That's the normal protocol for inflammation. It's called rice, rest, ice. I forgot the rest of the acronym. But that's for physical therapy for car project you you you rest an area that's injured you ice an area that's injured.
So that that that ice will decrease inflammation. But the truth is some people putting ice on an area actually causes muscle contraction irritation and more inflammation.
So everybody's a little bit different. Some people get into cryotherapy tank and they just feel so much better afterwards.
You're only in there like a minute or something like that. You feel so much better after it. Some people it makes the feel worse. So you just kind of try that.
There's certainly not any pro any negatives to try cryotherapy. So cryotherapy is cold therapy.
I had an appointment with my surgeon yesterday asked if she ever had ever heard of a tumor becoming walled off since you had mentioned that of course she had never heard of that.
How would you explain that to conventional doctor.
Well, I would explain anything to conventional doctor. They've never heard of a tumor becoming walled off because they removed them or they do chemotherapy or radiation. I mean, they just are our hammering these things with nuclear bomb. So they're not going to see that that often.
I don't know why a person would not say they haven't seen that. I mean, good to say. I shared with you my comment of a person with lung cancer with these with these tumors that had grown at all for two years and the surgeon kept digging this person that we need to go in there take those out of where they're where she's going to die she finally complied.
They went in there for surgery and the surgeons and oh my gosh, they broke apart like puff balls and the surgeon, the surgery took them like three times longer because you don't know this debris because there's all that tissue.
To say that they've never seen something like that. I have no idea.
Oh, thank you for the rest of the acronym compress and elevate is there a low number of for sodium levels that would require IV electrolytes.
Or is it symptoms that determinant not my dropped to one 21 from one 27 last week. I think it's a side effect of the immune therapy. It certainly might be.
If you could Google side effects.
Certainly, yes, you can go in and get an IV that would be the fastest way to raise those levels.
You need some pink salt, putting some pink salt on your food using pink salt.
You could add some pink salt to water and drink it. That's a good way to get sodium levels up, but the fastest way is through an IV.
Could black sand draw cancer from a lymph node through the lip passages out through my curb of current will be opening.
Well, I know this person asking the question. And for this person, I would say, yes, it certainly possibly could.
If it's surrounded by anything is possible. Once you have that opening to tissue, it seems to draw.
So we've had people use black sand and a draw continues to draw the cancer from who knows where.
And they have to use it, you know, doesn't times where it's continuing to draw and produce it as gone fall off.
So yes, it certainly can.
Prior to chemotherapy, my breast tumors were moving up to the surface of the skin and shrinking sense, completed six chemotherapy treatments.
The tumors have continued to shrink 40 to 60%.
But have moved away from the skin. Also, I'm.
Also, I'm sure part of the shrinking too.
So yeah, it could appear to be moving away from the skin, but it's actually just because the tumor shrinking.
That's what you're saying. Is there anything to do that will help move the tumors back towards my skin.
Or is that an immune response that might happen.
That's decreased and starting chemo. Yeah, that's a good question. I don't know. There's, isn't anything that's necessarily going to draw them more towards the skin.
You know, when you're done with chemo and we see, we might see that change.
Turns out if you're going to have to do it.
I'll unpack to be after chemo.
I have not received a program. I will see where we're at in your works.
If that has been completed.
Tell me, understand what does it mean that the tumor has been walled off.
Does a wall of healthy tissue literally grow around the tumor prevented further tumor growth.
Yes, it can. So how your body can walk off a tumor. Is it just literally.
You end up with a fibrous tissue around the tumor. So you still have this tumor there that now, you know, over the course of time the tumor has it grown for, you know, you know, months or years.
So if the tumor has it grown or for months or years, it's really not actually like cancer anymore.
So cancer is defined by cells that are in rapid replication. And if they're in rapid replication, they are going to be getting they're going to the tumor itself is going to be getting larger with hard tumor.
So it's your body is just stopped that has just stopped growing and you can end up just getting a protective layer of fibrous tissue around it.
As I continue with chemo, my body is increasingly hyper sensitive. I am already on a long history diet, but I am seemingly increasingly histamine sensitive what it makes sense to add histamine blocker supplement or something.
It's quite possible. So the histamine blocker supplements that are out there as we have a product called histic clear, which is the DAO enzyme that helps break down histamine in your gut, whether it's made in the gut because of the hypersensitivity reaction to a food or something like that or anything that's causing histamine production in the gut.
Or it's your consuming histamines in your diet. That's what that will do. The DAO enzyme doesn't absorb and get into the system very well. So it mainly stays in the gut. So the purpose of the DAO enzyme is to break down histamines in the gut in the limit of the gut.
That's called histic clear. We also have a couple other histamine products that have different nutrients in it that are known to help decrease histamines in the tissue. So what is called histamine scavenger, what is natural clear histrate to different products.
One might work really well for one person and not for another. So you got to experiment with this.
And then we also have different things that will just decrease inflammation. So other things that will just decrease inflammation. You're probably on like the flavonoids, like curcumid and respiratory cream tea extract and things like that.
So you have to experiment and see if that will help. Unfortunately, chemo does damage a lot of healthy cells and could cause issues.
I've listened to a talk about the pH miracle trading cancer by Dr. Young recommending drinking sodium bicarbonate water says 2 to 3 teaspoons to a liter of water and testing your urine pH. What do you think of that?
I've noticed my pH is 8.0 urine after sleeping with my right frequencies consistently.
So anybody that's been with me for a very long knows my philosophy of this book and it just doesn't jive.
That's just my opinion. So from a physiological standpoint, it just does not make any sense physiologically just understanding physiology 101.
If you're going to drink sodium bicarbonate, which is very alkaline on the pH scale, IPH.
You all you're going to really be doing is alkalizing your stomach because you're going to break your body's going to break down sodium bicarbonate into sodium and carbonate and you won't absorb it as sodium bicarbonate.
So all you're going to be doing is, you know, it can be a source of sodium, but your body's going to break that down. You're not alkalizing the rest of your body by doing that.
The benefit by alkalizing your stomach, you can be actually causing other health problems because you won't digest your food very well because you need the HCL in your stomach to break down your proteins and your carbohydrates in your stomach.
So you then will send food boluses to your large to your small intestine only partially digested and put more stress on your on your small intestine that you're got.
So I am not a fan of this. I'm not a fan of testing your urine pH.
Your urine pH does not equate to your cellular pH and your tissue pH, nor does your salivary pH correlate to your tissue pH.
All it does is correlate to your urine pH and you can get an increase your pH and more alkaline urine by just eating a better diet because you're getting more minerals and you'll spill more minerals into your urine, which will raise your pH.
So when a person changes their diet and eats a better diet that is eating more plant-based foods and they're getting more plant-based minerals.
So remember you need plant-based minerals for your body. You'll get enough and you'll dump what you don't need and you will raise your pH.
So that's the best way to do it. Draking sodium by carbonate just, I just, I don't know, sorry, it just does not make any sense physiologically and I don't beat to bash someone who has a theory but physiologically it just doesn't, I just can't understand it.
So maybe if somebody smarter than me would explain it to me it would be helpful. Any other questions?
I do the prebiotics and probiotics in sunscreen that you have provided create or provide for butyrate to treat leaky gut. I have read that butyrate is a great way for practically got. Yes, I would totally agree with that butyrate is a great way of helping fix leaky gut.
Your body makes butyrate from prebiotics that's why you would take prebiotics and you have prebiotics would be fiber is a prebiotic and so a prebiotic is a indigestible, a done digestible fiber that you break down and you make butyrate or butyric acid.
So you can take butyrate directly we have that product as well. So somebody with a really bad leaky gut can take butyrate we have a product from the sides for health called try butyrate or something like that.
So that's a great source of butyrate in the three forms so it can help with leaky gut but sunscreen can do that same thing. So unless you have a really, really bad leaky gut then there are some other things you want to do with so good question.
Okay, if there's any other questions I will close this up hopefully it will record and save and I can upload it.
Say it prayer please and we'll have it up on the site.
Thank you guys and we'll see everybody next week.
Bye bye.